okay let's get to our last set of
audience questions before the
thanksgiving break just a reminder we'll
be off on thursday friday for the
thanksgiving holiday the show isn't
canceled we'll be back monday and
just taking a couple of days off uh
first question
today via you via the audience can
donald trump beat joe biden with the
faithless electors
scenario that is being drawn out so
i want to explore this now i want to say
up front
this is 99.9 pure fantasy
i'm going to give you sort of the two
versions of this
that that exist and we'll talk about why
neither is going to happen so the the
way that the election works is that each
state holds an election
massachusetts gets a result and florida
gets a result and california gets a
result and
if donald trump wins florida florida
sends republican electors
to cast florida's electoral votes for
donald trump
and if joe biden wins massachusetts and
california as he did massachusetts and
california have
democratic electors uh chosen by the
party
uh tend to be very loyal to to the party
um cast their electoral votes for joe
biden so
the first faithless elector scenario is
the simpler one
which is you have electors that revolt
for some reason they don't have faith
in the candidate that their state has
voted for so a democratic elector from
massachusetts for his example says
i don't care that i'm a democratic
elector i don't care that
the state voted for joe biden i will
vote instead
electorally for donald trump instead of
joe biden now that would be one l one
elector that needs to do that
it is always very unlikely that you're
going to have any significant number of
those there were two for donald trump in
2016. remember donald trump
won 306 electoral votes but in the end
got 304 because of two faithless
electors okay
this time because joe biden likewise has
306 electoral votes
you'd need 36 electors to be faithless
and flip
to get to a tie in which the house of
representatives controlled by democrats
would vote
or you would need 37 electors to be
faithless and flip
to hand donald trump an electoral
college victory it's a fantasy
it's simply not going to happen uh
period and um it is
you know there is that that is just
simply not going to happen
so then there's this other idea and
this was written about before the
election and i covered it extensively
and we've talked about it a few times
which is a strategy in which if you have
a state
with a republican legislature and a
republican governor
that biden won they could choose
to send republican electors anyway
to vote for donald trump even if joe
biden won
the popular vote in the state um
it's not going to happen and the reason
that's not going to happen is as i
mentioned you need both
the governor and the legislature to do
it
if you have just the legit so first of
all you're only looking at states biden
one
because you need to flip those states
you look at states biden one with
republican
legislatures you first need republican
legislators willing to do it
and then in addition if you get a
republican legislature willing to do it
you need a republican governor who is
not willing to veto it and there simply
aren't enough states
meeting these characteristics uh to make
that a possibility
and it it even if they were willing
morally even if they had no problem with
this ideologically or whatever the case
may be
they're not going to be able to do it
now just
for the sake of exploring imagine that
somehow they figured out a way
to manipulate electors or convince
electors or bribe electors or whatever
the case may be
in order to flip the results for donald
trump what the hell happens
internationally
what th the the presidency would be seen
as an illegitimate presidency
internationally
this would be different than you know
you think back to the year
2000 and florida and hanging chads
and the idea of george w bush is an
illegitimate president
it did not impact you know countries
accepted that george w
bush was president i believe that if
donald trump were somehow to figure out
a way to use this elector scheme to
reverse the results
um i i believe that he is seen as a
completely illegitimate president
internationally in a way
we've never seen before but we don't
even have to hypothesize we don't even
have to wonder
because it's not going to happen joe
biden's going to be
sworn in on january 20th the only
scenario that could
delay but not stop this
is one i'm going to talk about a little
bit later on in this segment
our sponsor purevpn is having a huge
black friday sale
right now they're giving you 88 office
subscription
which comes out to only a little over a
dollar a month
purevpn makes you anonymous when you're
browsing online
and you can trust them because they're
the only vpn in the industry with an
always-on third-party audit to verify
that your internet activity is not being
logged by hiding your ip address purevpn
keeps you safe from hackers
and prevents you from being spied on by
your internet service provider
social media companies and even
government surveillance
it also lets you watch shows and movies
that aren't available in your country
purevpn is super fast you can use it on
all of your devices
and i can tell you firsthand the app is
really easy to use
and they have 6500 servers across the
world which is more than any other vpn
in the industry everyone should be using
a vpn when connecting to the internet
and now is the perfect time to start
because purevpn
is giving you an 88 discount on a
subscription
which comes out to only a little over a
dollar a month
go to davidpakman.com purevpn
the link is underneath the video